lo que quiero realizar en este vídeo es
pensar cómo podríamos hacer la derivada
de expresiones que representan un
producto en esta ocasión ya no son sólo
dos funciones son ahora tres y lo que
haré es que usando las herramientas lo
que sabemos para el producto de dos
funciones lo utilizaré aquí y la forma
en cómo lo estaba yo pensando es que
como podríamos ver este producto como
reescribirlo para que se viera como dos
funciones y lenguas y tomar sus
derivadas por separado
entonces si entendemos lo que nos dice
en la regla de producto esto sería la
derivada respecto de x de fx y no vayas
a olvidar y cerrando tus paréntesis
bueno aquí lo puse con mismo color pero
mejor lo pondré de blanco para no
confundirnos porque si no te puede
causar conflicto y esto irá x gdx que a
su vez esto irá x hd x y luego entonces
viene la segunda parte que sería más f x
como la simple función por la derivada
de los demás donde esto viene siendo la
derivada respecto de x
de la función g x x hdx pero si puedes
recordar aquí esto viene siendo otra vez
un producto lo que hay perdón tatiana de
cupo h baja por hdx entonces lo que aquí
pasaría es que tendríamos otra vez que
aplicar la regla de producto entonces lo
pondré por acá abajo desglosado entonces
ahorita nos concentraremos con lo que va
a pasar por aquí que viene siendo g
prima o la derivada de ge de x por hdx
como simple en función más gx en su
forma de función por la derivada de h de
x o h prima así que lo que tenemos aquí
será la derivada de g de x por hdx que
es lo que acabamos de anotar por aquí
entonces ahora vamos a escribir todo el
conjunto y de una forma un poquito más
desarrollada entonces lo que acabo de
subrayar por aquí sería entonces f prima
de x que es la derivada respecto de x df
de x
por g de equis y así está a su vez por h
de x más ahora aquí adelante lo que
tendremos que hacer va a ser distribuir
esta f x que está con este producto y
sería primero con este término y luego
con este de acá entonces escribiéndolo
nos quedaría fx por g prima de x y
alavés por hb x así es x h de x entonces
sigue uno más pero bueno lo voy a
escribir de color blanco para no
confundirnos sería más
efe de x por gdx y ahora sería por h
prima de x o la derivada de hd x y esto
finalmente viene siendo exactamente lo
mismo que cuando nosotros teníamos dos
funciones multiplican los el producto de
dos funciones pero en este caso tenemos
tres pero ya supimos cómo llevarlo a
cabo y como puedes ver ahora tenemos
tres términos y cada uno tiene una
derivada de cada una de las funciones
aquí es f prima de x
prima de x y h prima de x lo que esto
nos dice es que que si tenemos cuatro
funciones entonces aquí nos deberían de
aparecer cuatro términos y cada uno de
estos con una respectiva derivada de
cada función y así lo podemos llevar y
generalizar hasta para n términos lo
cual sería con la misma ideología